eric fetty rough career numbers against
atlanta
for games three starts owen one with a
12 plus cra
well ronald started the game yesterday
about as well as you can a first pitch
homer off max scherzer for his 20th
career leadoff homer
and acuna with a bolt to left field
that's headed for the left field corner
stevenson will gather that
and acuna is on his way to second a
booming double and the braves are back
to work against this washington staff
so the nationals aren't going to pitch
to freddie freeman not surprisingly in a
run scoring spot they'll set up a double
play chance
it's up to dansby with two outs and the
bases loaded he's two for 14 at the
plate
and that one got by luke croy that's
gonna ricochet off the signage and
acuna gets home anyway so that one
popped into and out of the leather of
lucroy and the braves get a gift and
take a one-nothing lead
as i said it's 77 degrees today
hopefully we felt like he had trouble
with his curveball
in the cold and win shouldn't have that
issue today
trey hit by a pitch and a base hit
yesterday the home run
that one's a long ball to left he's done
it again
see you later trey turner
a good set one two combo looking at the
top of the lineup
i can't do much better than that
[Music]
second home run of the year for turner
two to one
good at bat by juan soto ryan zimmerman
two for four opening day this one into
right
nothing they can do but watch it drop
ryan heading for second
over to third is soto and ryan
zimmerman's three for five
with his first extra base hit
here's starlin castro castro out to
short center
ball falling and it's on the ground
zimmerman to third soto
home it's three to one
and the nets are blasting and bleeding
atlanta here early
[Applause]
breaking up andrew stevenson freed a
long way from getting out of this unless
he
can induce a double play ground ball
yeah this one to left tagging
heading home ryan zimmerman throw by
ozuna
about eight feet off line and ryan
zimmerman
screaming down the line and that's lead
four to one
austin riley with a single you'd love
for the bottom of the order to set the
table for the top of the order make a
lot of noise here in the second inning
indorinciarte getting a start today he
hit 190 last season
3-1 count and he flies toward left
center that ball is going to carry out
to the track robler still going can't
get it it's off the wall
riley had to hold up at second base
he'll now move to third and stand there
as ender puts a charge into one and
drives it off the wall in left center
field and the braves are in business
second and third nobody out for the
pitcher
aunt freed a little chopper over the
mound everybody's gonna be safe and a
run is in max freight has an infield hit
and the braves score austin riley to
make it 4-2
so the braves finally get a soft hit to
go their way so 32 pitches for
fetty who is in deep trouble now acuna
doubled and scored in the first inning
there's a ball shot the other way past
perez
streaking around third is inciarte he
will score
free goes first to third and we've got a
one run game it's four to three
well here's your chance ozzy old for 17.
fly ball with depth would tie the game
second and third nobody out and on the
ground right side that's going to get a
run home
trey turner had to get rid of it in a
big hurry but a great at-bat for ozzy
albies that's his first rbi
max freed comes home to tie the game
it's a 4-4
score two down and here's travis darno
he is the eighth brave to the plate here
in the second inning
now we got ourselves a slugfest in dc a
4-4 ball game at the top of the second
swing and a high fly ball that's wallah
deep toward left center field that one's
into
the base of the wall on the warning
track and the braves are going to get a
couple of runs out of it
darno with a big bolt that almost left
the ballpark
freddie freeman scores from first to
cunha from third and
fetty's given up that three-run lead the
braves respond with five in the second
and lead it six to four now
ryan zimmerman bloop double right field
line
first time he waited for that one and
hits it out to the gap
over to cut it off in ciarte
on soto to third and ryan zimmerman is
absolutely locked in here's castro
he blooped a rbi single out to center
his last time
and there's another rbi hit this will
move
zimmerman all the way over to third and
ciarte with that strong arm it's cut off
and
then that's are back to 6'5
so now jonathan lukroy it's a 6'5 game
riley diving stop catcher running strong
throw what a play
for austin riley and that's lefty sam
play making his major league debut
well well he gets the call for a kid
that went to georgia tech
and is facing a guy that he's grown up
watching in freddie freeman for that to
be his first major league strikeout
that's something he'll remember the rest
of his life players will have
albies freeman and ozuna coming up
looking to extend
a six to five lead for their first win
of the year
there's a shot in the right field a
well-struck single for ozzy albee's and
he's on the board
that had to feel good his first hit in
20 trips
freddie freeman wasn't happy with a
called third strike
against sam clay last time up freddie
smokes it into right center field that's
down for a hit
ozzy around second he's flying toward
third helmet didn't come off this time
and the braves were in business hats off
to freddie freeman the braves rolling
first and third nobody out big hole
right side if ozuna can poke one through
with zimmerman holding freeman at first
base
and that one got away from luke roy and
that's going to bring home an insurance
run the ball ends up in the camera well
thank you very much braves got a run in
the first on a pass ball now they get a
run on a wild pitch
and that helps 7-5 your score the inning
starts with an ozzy all these single
he looked terrific this spring here's a
chance for him to nail down the first
victory of the season for the braves and
he's got to get soto first who's reached
three times
two via walks and here is soto this time
leading off and the pitch fastball
inside ball four
soto gets the lead off walk from smith
castro base it to center one to right
two rbis today that's fair into the left
field corner
juan soto thinking about scoring bob
henley will send him
this is a one-run game at 7-6
and castro has driven in three graves
still
lead but two on one out and stevenson
the batter
a little roller back to the mound second
base one onto first it's in time
that is your ball game will smith
survives the seventh inning and the
braves hang on and beat the nationals
7-6